what's going on guys this is Rob and
this morning when we were doing our
comics and coffee which is my weekly Q&A
where I just answer the questions that
you guys give me to the best of my
ability one of you guys had thrown out
the comment of stating that the Infinity
stones or at least as they've appeared
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe seem to
spell out the word Thanos that the
tesseract which is the space stone of
course sorts for the tea that the ether
which is the reality stone starts with
an a that the power stone which is the
orb starts with an O and of course that
the sceptre of Loki which houses the
mine stone begins with an S and so the
question is if this is true if the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is basically
giving us a template whereby we can I
guess guess in a more educated fashion
what the Infinity stones are then the
question becomes if we don't know what
the soul stone is which presumably
begins with the letter H and we don't
know what the time stone is which again
presumably begins with the letter n then
can we guess and B right can we get that
accurate and so what we're going to do
in this video is we're going to put that
to the test we're going to see if we
can't figure out where the soul stone is
and where the time stone is now in my
personal opinion we're going to go ahead
and jump with a jump of the soul stone
here but in my personal opinion there
are two possibilities for the location
of the soul stone because it starts with
the letter H it's one of two people
the first one is Heimdall and heimdal
seems to be the most popular choice for
the soul stone and the reason why I say
that is because with Heimdall as we know
the soul stone is orange and the eyes of
Heimdall seemed to be orange
but more so than that people look at
this sort of or this seems to be on the
chest plate of his outfit and people
seem to point to that and say with those
two things combined it seems evident
that Heimdall has or is in possession of
the of the soul stone I would say this
is probably not the case on the reason
why I would say that is because
Heimdall's eyes are still orange even
when he's not when even when he doesn't
have that orb on his chest plate in the
first Thor film not only that the powers
of Heimdall in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are the exact same as the
are in the comic books where he
basically has enhanced senses he can see
pretty much everything he can hear
pretty much everything and he uses those
abilities to basically be the watch man
for Asgard itself now I think that the
second theory here is the more on the
more likely of the to my second person
here is Adam warlock and the reason why
I say Adam warlock is because in the
Marvel Comics when Adam warlock was
first introduced Adam warlock didn't
have a name when he was first discovered
by the Fantastic Four he was not
referred to as Adam warlock instead he
was simply just referred to as him h-i-m
more so than that Adam warlock has an
extremely intricate history with the
soul stone or the soul gem as it's
referred to in the comic books he is the
one person among all people who have
ever been in possession of the soul
stone that have a very in-depth and
intimate understanding of how the soul
stone works what the intricate nature's
of its power is what the very basis and
the fundamental principle of this whole
stone is he's really the one person that
knows that stone better than anybody
else and so it would make perfect sense
that Adam warlock would be in possession
of it now in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
we know that Adam warlock exists whether
we'll actually see him or not is a whole
different beast but we know that by
virtue of the end credits scene in Thor
the dark world and the scene in the
museum in guardians of the galaxy that
the cocoon of Adam warlock was housed
within the Museum of Tana Lear to Vaughn
of the collector that is the
regenerative cocoon that Adam warlock
uses whenever he's bringing himself back
to life basically as a chance for him to
gain his energies back into a human form
and then he emerges from this cocoon the
same way that you would expect a
butterfly to emerge from a chrysalis
that's basically how Adam warlock
functions continuing this trend of each
of these items appearing to somehow case
or in case a infinity stone and being
named after the letters we're going to
jump to the letter n to the last one
here and while a lot of people are
speculating they really are they're
really not sure they're really kind of
throwing things out in the air that seem
to be very very random here I would go
as far as to say that this stone is
probably in the possession of dr. Steven
strange and that this stone is probably
the necklace which is the eye of
agamotto now the eye of
moto is an extremely important artifact
for the realm of dr. strange I would go
as far as to say that's probably the
single most important artifact and he's
in possession of if not the most popular
the eye of agamotto has a vast array of
different abilities for dr. strange the
eye of agamotto allows him to see
through enchantments of other people he
can teleport to other dimensions it's a
very intricate aspect he can basically
open portals across the entire universe
in fact the eye of agamotto played a
very important role during the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline which in which it was
basically used by dr. strange to
teleport the earthbound heroes to the
shrine of mistress death the Thanos had
built where he was basically waging war
against the universe that's how they got
there that's how they fought fought
Thanos was using the eye of agamotto to
teleport back and forth and so it would
seem to me that even if this isn't
necessarily the case but is very fitting
argument a very reasonable argument that
the time stone is basically the necklace
of dr. Stephen strange and the form of
the eye of agamotto but here's my
question what do you guys think where do
you guys think that these Infinity
stones are if you don't believe that the
soul soul is a positioning Adam warlock
and if you don't believe the time stone
is in possession of dr. Stephen strange
then what do you think they are because
I'm really interested to see the
responses that you guys have with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later
he never you